-Tyler Perry, everybody!
We're hanging out
with Tyler Perry!
New movie "Don't Look Up" is
in select theaters December 10th
and on Netflix December 24th.
"Don't Look Up" -- The cast
in this movie is insane,
by the way.
-It's crazy.
-Leonardo DiCaprio,
Jennifer Lawrence,
Meryl Streep, Jonah Hill,
Ariana Grande,
Timothée Chalamet,
Cate Blanchett,
Mark Rylance, Kid Cudi.
Adam McKay directed this.
-And me.
How the hell did I get in there?
I'm just like, how the hell
did I get in this?
-How was it?
What's it like going with --
'Cause you worked
with Adam McKay before.
-Yeah, I played Colin Powell
on "Vice."
And I loved that experience,
loved working with him.
He's such a -- He knows
exactly what he wants.
He knows the humor, the timing.
It's just great
working with him.
But he also gives you
the freedom to help create,
help create the characters
and so on and so forth.
-He's one of
the best improvisers
I've ever seen in my life.
-He's so good, man.
He'll be in the back, I'll hear
a voice saying, "Say this."
And I'll say it,
and just everybody's out.
So, he's great.
-No, he's unbelievably funny.
Does Leo improvise, as well?
-You know, for those -- First
of all, when I first met them,
they were all -- they were like,
"Okay, hey, I'm Leo,"
"I'm Jennifer," "I'm Ariana."
I'm like, "I know
who all of you are.
I'm like, I just -- Like, "Hi!"
So we all sit down, and we start
the scene right away.
And I had to just
keep reminding myself,
"Don't come out of character
because you're sitting here
with these Oscar winners.
Just stay in character."
But they were so mesmerizing
in their performances.
So, wasn't a lot of -- I don't
know if he was ad-libbing,
but what he was doing
I believed.
He's that damn good.
And you all -- we all know that.
-Yeah, Leonardo DiCaprio,
he's one of the best.
And Ariana Grande,
by the way, can act.
-And funny.
-And super funny.
-She's hysterical.
If she wanted to give up
that little singing thing
that's not going too well
and just do comedy, she could.
-She could, actually, yeah.
Do you want to tell everyone
what "Don't Look Up" is about?
-Yeah, it's poking fun,
but not really,
at our whole society and
how ridiculous we've become.
And when something
serious happens
that could destroy us all,
we don't take it seriously
because we're all so divided,
kind of like reality.
But it's so -- just --
You got a clip?
Can they see the clip?
-Yes, I have a clip.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Tyler Perry
in "Don't Look Up."
Take a look.
-It's somewhere between six and
nine kilometers across, so...
-It's big.
-...it would damage the entire
planet, not just a house.
You know.
-The entire planet.
Okay, well, as it's damaging,
will it hit this one house
in particular
that's right on the coast
of New Jersey?
It's my ex-wife's house.
I need it to be hit.
-Come on, you and Shelly
have a great relationship.
You stop.
-Listen, in all --
-You need to stop!
-I will, but in all fairness,
I actually paid for the house!
-I'm sorry. Are we --
Are we not being clear?
We're trying to tell you
that the entire planet
is about to be destroyed.
-Okay.
Well, it's, um, you know, just
something we do around here.
You know, we just keep
the bad news light.
-Right.
It helps the medicine go down.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Well done, man!
Well played.
Tyler Perry, everybody!
"Don't Look Up" is in select
theaters December 10th
and on Netflix December 24th.